so I drink a lot of water I go to the
gym and I sweat it up and I know I talk
about the gym a lot but dude this is not
even like I actually have a story about
it
I know I joke around about how I got the
teardrops and all that and yeah I do
it's fine right
there I got the hamstrings that'll choke
someone out and I get it and that's fine
and that's cool right
like I walk around like I'm a you know
what I mean like I could be it doesn't I
can run backwards just as fast as I can
run forwards okay
but what I'm saying is
yes I do work out and I'm not I'm no
stranger to the gym the iron Paradise I
get it I'm the mayor of this [__]
place I need to go on I need to check
the citizens you know what I'm saying so
I go
and I get I got I go to the gym and I'm
working it out I'm sweaty as [__] you
know
go back to a grocery store after that
I'm shopping some dude comes up to me I
know I know I joke around about how I do
legs all the time but check this out
for size
once you [__] Feast your eyes on
Feast your ears on listening to this if
you're watching the if you're watching
the show Feast your eyes on me saying
this
but the guy comes up to me says hey man
you work out at the gym right did I go
to and I was like oh yeah what's up bro
he's like hey man cool and I said cool
man
he says hey man
um
you work out legs a lot
and I say oh yeah man I do I work out
legs you know I think that's the most
important thing to work out and he goes
like this yeah man and he said respect
and I go thanks yeah thanks man yeah
walks away
dude are you kidding me
[Music]
[__] talk about making my day dude
I walked out of that place
[Music]
and it was just
I mean it was killer
I mean yeah I go to the gym it's
operation do it to him but it's just
like it's absolutely you know it's crazy
dude
respect who even says that anymore it's
like it's
respect